es ist dienstag das heißt herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode tape.tv direkt wieder an wird
den besten tipp user bilderwelt wie
heißt ja nochmal was die
do
entspannt sekunde meines lebens
verschwendet auf diesem schild steht
ende aber wie wir sehen ist das gar
nicht das ende
[Musik]
da kann ich sagen es war nicht besser
nee ich hab ich wohl besser wissen als
ging lisa du bist 17
ja das gibt sich nicht ganz aus meine
liebe
doch papa wurde erst papa als ich auf
die welt kam
ich meine sie hat recht
in ist
ist
sie hat recht deuce
talk ist ob jeder kennt diese situation
und ich glaube auch dass jeder
mindestens einen freund beziehungsweise
eine freundin hat die genauso drauf ist
wir haben allerdings alle nicht einen
freund in unserem freundeskreis der so
drauf ist wie die person im nächsten
test einfach king louie zu hause gehen
[Musik]
der einen seite total witzig oder
anderen seite will ich mich auch scheiße
weil ich darüber lachen
ein autoschlüssel
ich liebe dich so sehr wie viele
verarschen gibt es auf diesen clip vom
wendler ich habe jetzt eben wie auch
gelesen dass er michael wendler jetzt
aber den oliver pocher anzeigen will
weil er da so hoch genommen hat kommt ja
das ist doch lustig die 25
das ist so die typische art von tik tok
die ich mir um drei uhr nachts im bett
dann schaue ich nicht ein rennen kann
[Musik]
also das war auf jeden fall das mit
abstand kreativ situation der einen
seite fühle ich mich extrem scheiße weil
ich weiß ich sag's an jedem dienstag
aber es ist mal wieder die wahrheit
[Musik]
es ist die wahrheit so ihr knick frei
übergehen und dann hier auch wieder
knick frei übergehen und dann soll das
ganze hier modelliert werden durch eine
funktion dritten grades also es von 100
nicht bei einer blitz frage ich glaube
schon das alphabet 32 und wieviel vokal
hat das einfach mit
64 wachsende alter der schule was ich
bin auf die nase der typ denkt halt
wirklich er beide fragen richtig
beantwortet dabei hatte nicht mehr eine
frage richtig beantwortet
wisst ihr die antwort schreibt gern mal
die kommentare im prozess auch holen
können wir es nicht kann ich ganz gut
vorstellen kann mich jetzt vorstellte
ja also es ist auf jeden fall ein guter
trick um am supermarkt an der schlange
vorbei und von mir träumte ich dann in
seinem traum mensch oder weil ich wie
denkt daher überhaupt naja wie wir
menschen kann da nicht denken so mit
wörtern nie weißt du dass ich ein talent
konnte
aha willst du es hört nicht bei jetzt
einfach okay ich mache
was
ich mich hier an
[Musik]
ganz im ernst kennt ihr auch diese
beiträge so würde dir den abend von
euren besten freund brechen für 30 euro
ja klar da würde ich in deine arme jeden
gast
[Musik]
ich fühle mich wieder extrem schädliche
lache auf diesem schild steht dass an
dieser stelle ein sammelplatz für
menschen ist aber wie wir sehen sind
hier gar keine menschen
das liegt daran dass man menschen für
einen sammelplatz für menschen benötigt
[Musik]
ja genau so sah ich vorgestern aus als
ich durch die sabine sturm gelaufen bin
so kann es sich jetzt am kiosk
[Musik]
ich frag mich
jedes mal wie viel langeweile okay ich
brauche ich gar nicht sagen ich habe
einen tipp wo ich 1000 milliarden
gummibärchen hingestellt habe
alles so grau
parameter
positiv
an alle die wir gerade sehen und denken
sich her dass es gespielt macht es
einfacher macht es nicht nur einerseits
möchte ich das jetzt auch probiert weil
es ist dass es klappt einfach so dass
man wirklich richtig bewusst ist aber
der kommt jetzt so richtig schwer und
dann fällt nach hinten aber macht es
nicht nach nicht dass es eben doch was
passiert macht es nicht zu hause nach
aber es klappt wirklich herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen ausgabe dass
hat luca auf seiner homepage möchtest du
ja als der hund aussieht du kannst doch
geht uns um ihr kommen weltstar
jetzt ist schluss mit dem backen
hörbücher dem sechzehnten jahrhundert
gemacht hat allerdings würde ich als
erster das heutige video zu beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch die
heutige episode tipps habt ihr sehr
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr darüber
einen daumen hoch von euch unter dem
video hier freuen ich heiß auf tik tok
laserdrucker schreibt mir euren tik tok
nahmen gerne in die kommentare
denn dann kommt ihr eventuell in die
nächste folge
[Musik]